a surge of migrants causing chaos in
Arizona the epicenter of the crisis is a
remot remote border town called
lukeville the CBP closed the lukeville
Port of Entry yesterday to redirect
border patrol officers to processing
migrants but some say the decision is
exacerbating the problem billan is live
there in lukeville Arizona tell us
more Dana good morning to you here in
lukeville we are quite literally in the
middle of nowhere 2 and 1/2 hours to the
closest major city thousands of crossing
here illegally every day and the
situation is completely unsustainable
we'll step out give you a look at the
scene here this is a mass of hundreds
upon hundreds of people who have crossed
the border illegally and are camped out
here at the border wall waiting to be
apprehended by border patrol you'll
quickly notice these are all single
adult men there is not a single woman or
child in this group you're looking at
and these guys are coming in from all
over the world large amounts of African
men from Sagal from Guinea from morania
from Egypt others from the Middle East
others from Asia this is border patrols
Tucson Arizona sector which just had
17,500 illegal Crossings last week alone
that is the highest weekly total ever
recorded we talked to one for this
sector we talked to one man from morania
who told us uh he paid Smugglers $10,000
to get here first flying into Colombia
we talked to another man from Guinea who
says once he's processed he plans to
head to New York City now you might be
wondering
how does this happen when we have the
border wall right here well there are
breaches all in the wall and we want to
show you this remarkable video we shot
yesterday take a look at this border
patrol and federal contractors were
trying to fix a hole in the wall that
Smugglers cut when a huge surge of
illegal immigrants came pushing through
that Gap trying to get into the United
States and successfully doing it before
border patrol could fix it they were
trying to weld it and all these people
started pushing through the hole in the
wall and you'll notice there's a human
Smuggler dressed in black right on the
other side of the wall he sees our
camera he kind of just gives us a shrug
and then salutes us uh essentially
saying there's nothing they can do about
it border patrol has been finding these
Cuts in the wall all over the place they
try to fix them there's nothing they can
do about it they say it's like a game of
whack-a-mole take a listen to what the
border patrol Union had to say out
here this is what has caused has been
caused by an open invitation by the
administration that said hey come one
Kamal ask for Asylum and you'll get
released it takes a toll on operation it
takes a toll on the men and women that
are out there putting their lives on the
line each and every
day elsewhere along the border take a
look at this video out of border patrol
San Diego sector news Nation capturing
this footage of a large amount of
Chinese male Nationals that crossed
illegally near the hakuma Hot Springs
area so this is happening all along our
Southern border guys the entire world is
showing up here at our doorstep they're
Crossing illegally and they are
expecting to get released here into the
United stes it's happening here in
lukeville it's happening in Eagle Pass
it's happening in San Diego Dana you
mentioned off the top the Port of Entry
here in lukeville is completely closed
down that is because CBP is surging
officers here to try try to help border
patrol deal with apprehending all these
folks on top of that all of the Border
Patrol checkpoints in the Tucson sector
in the local highways have also been
closed down those checkpoints are
invaluable for trying to be a second
line of defense in stopping both human
Smugglers and Fentanyl Smugglers so it's
all hands- on Deck here guys and you can
see the situation completely
unsustainable about 2,000 to 3,000
crossing right here every single day
bill in that live shot we could just
hear a lot of yelling do you know what
they were
saying what they're doing is they they
get mad if anybody tries to cut the line
here so new people will cross illegally
and they don't think they have to wait
in line so they'll try and to they'll
try to walk up to the front and then
you'll hear the guys hooting and
hollering and whistling at them trying
to get border Patrol's attention to say
Hey you better get to the back of the
line some of us have been waiting here a
long time but the bottom line guys all
these folks they expect to be processed
and released into the United States and
again we talked to one guy who said he
plans to head to New York City others
heading to different cities but they're
not showing up here and turning
themselves into border patrol because
they think they're going to get deported
they they're going to be released into
the United States and they're willing to
camp out here and wait for it yeah hang
with us bill I mean we G so much
attention rightfully so for the war in
the Middle East we've gotten away a
little bit from the story but Bill if
you went by a roow from where you are it
take you 152 Mi to get to Tucson it take
you 195 Mi to get to Yuma I mean so when
you describe you're in the middle of
nowhere you're exactly right about that
mhm yeah it's a huge problem for border
patrol with Transportation too I mean
there's not even a McDonald's anywhere
out here guys the only food we can get
is at a gas station and you can see off
in the distance border patrol is trying
to process these people out Brian if we
can pan to the left real quick you can
see they're trying to process these
folks out as fast as they can but it
they're not getting anywhere because
because there's a constant flow of
people coming across so they'll send
people out on buses and they've got so
far to go um you know they're really not
making a dent in the population right
here camping out there's campfire set
all over the place there's trash all
over the place the smell of human feces
is in the air um I really haven't seen a
situation like this since a couple years
ago when we had those 20,000 Haitians
under the bridge in Del Rio but border
patrol completely overwhelmed out here
guys and their morale is Rock Bottom
having to deal with this okay great
reporting the cartels knowwhere to go
yet again thank you Bill